picture this you win a trip to Egypt to
see the Sphinx and the pyramids you love
ancient monuments so you fly to Cairo
the smell is awful but that won't stop
you you catch a yellow bus heading
towards Giza you're checking out the
sights through the bus window when you
suddenly realize that the guy sitting
next to you is wearing a suicide vest
he's a terrorist heading to the Sphinx
to blow it up because images are
forbidden in Islam unless you're a
prepubescent girl in which case they'll
let you slide just ask Aisha your new
Jihadi friend doesn't want to draw
attention to himself because he's on a
mission so he tries to distract you by
asking
why do Christians call Jesus the son of
God
what do you say
are you ready to answer him
trust me it's a good idea to plan out
your response now before it happens so
why do Christians call Jesus the son of
God
according to the Quran Christians call
Jesus the son of God because we're
imitating the pagans Surah 9 verse 30.
and the Jews say Ezra is the son of
Allah and the Christians say the Messiah
is the son of Allah that is the saying
with their mouths they imitate the
saying of those who disbelieved of old
Allah himself fighteth against them how
perverse are they
it's ironic that the Quran accuses Jews
and Christians of imitating pagans when
some of Islam's most basic practices
like taking the pilgrimage to Mecca
walking circles around the Kaaba kissing
the black stone and so on were copied
directly from Idol worshiping pagans but
let's ignore that for now so Jews and
Christians are perverse because we
imitate the unbelievers of old this
verse comes right after Surah 9 verse 29
where Allah commands his followers to
violently subjugate Jews and Christians
verse 30 provides the justification for
subjugating us Jews and Christians have
to be subjugated because we're actually
polytheists according to the Quran
strange I thought Islam was the religion
of peace of course Allah says that Jews
call Ezra the son of Allah
have you ever in your entire life
anywhere on the planet heard a Jew
calling Ezra the son of Allah
neither have I neither has anyone
so as is so often the case Allah doesn't
seem to know what he's talking about
when he's commanding his followers to
violently subjugate people
but even though he's wrong about Jews
here is he right about Christians do
Christians call Jesus the son of God
because we're imitating the unbelievers
of old
or do we call Jesus the son of God
because he was identified as the Son of
God by a mind-boggling unparalleled
cloud of witnesses
let's find out
Jesus was baptized by John the Baptist
and in Matthew 3 when Jesus comes out of
the water the spirit of God descends as
a dove and a voice out of the heavens
proclaims this is my beloved Son with
whom I am well pleased
a voice out of the heavens says this is
my beloved Son which means that the
voice was the voice of the father
but how do we know whom the father was
referring to
how do we know he wasn't talking about
John the Baptist or someone else
well the Holy Spirit descended from
heaven and landed on Jesus notice the
father and the Holy Spirit together
identify Jesus as the son of God
and Jesus repeatedly identifies himself
as the Son of God at his trial for
instance in Mark 14 the high priest asks
him are you the Christ the son of the
Blessed Jesus answers I am and you will
see the son of man seated at the right
hand of power and coming with the Clouds
Of Heaven
so Father Son and Holy Spirit are in
complete agreement that Jesus is the
Divine Son of God
in Luke 1 the angel Gabriel says to Mary
do not be afraid Mary for you have found
favor with God and behold you will
conceive in your womb and bear a son and
you shall call his name Jesus he will be
great and will be called the son of the
most high
Jesus is to be called the son of the
most high according to the angel Gabriel
what about the prophets John the Baptist
was a prophet according to both
Christianity and Islam in John 1 he
tells his followers about Jesus and says
I have seen and have borne witness that
this is the son of God
that's the testimony of the prophets how
about Jesus apostles
at the end of John 1 the Apostle
Nathanael says to Jesus Rabbi you are
the Son of God you are the king of
Israel
in Matthew 16 Jesus asks his disciples
who do you say that I am Peter answers
you are the Christ the son of the Living
God
now if Jesus were just a Prophet this
would have been a really good time to
rebuke Peter instead Jesus says to him
blessed are you Simon barjona for flesh
and blood has not revealed this to you
but my father who is in heaven
in Matthew 14 Jesus walks on water
during a storm after stepping into the
boat the wind stops and his disciples
Bow Down and Worship Him saying truly
you are the son of God
but it's not just his male followers who
call him the Son of God in John 11
Lazarus dies and Martha the sister of
Lazarus meets Jesus on his way to raise
Lazarus from the dead we read
Jesus said to her your brother will rise
again Martha said to him I know that he
will rise again in the Resurrection on
the last day Jesus said to her I am the
resurrection and the life whoever
believes in me though he die yet shall
he live and everyone who lives and
Believes In Me shall never die do you
believe this she said to him yes Lord I
believe that you are the Christ the son
of God who is coming into the world
Martha and the apostles and John the
Baptist were all Jews who believed in
Jesus but even the Jewish leaders who
rejected Jesus admitted that he was
claiming to be the Son of God at his
crucifixion they mocked him and said he
saved others he cannot save himself he
is the king of Israel let him come down
now from the cross and we will believe
in him he trusts in God let God deliver
him now if he desires him for he said I
am the son of God
so whether they believed him or didn't
believe him the Jews of his time
acknowledged that Jesus was claiming to
be the son of God and even some of the
Romans called Jesus the son of God when
Jesus died by crucifixion there was an
earthquake and the Roman Centurion and
those who were with him shouted truly
this was the son of God
even demons would call Jesus the son of
God as he was casting them out of people
we read in Luke 4 and demons also came
out of many crying you are the son of
God
now think about the diversity of
witnesses we have here the father
identifies Jesus as the Son of God Jesus
identifies himself as the Son of God the
Holy Spirit identifies Jesus as the Son
of God the angel Gabriel identifies
Jesus as the Son of God the prophet John
the Baptist identifies Jesus as the Son
of God Jesus Apostles identify him as
the Son of God Martha identifies him as
the Son of God Roman soldiers identify
him as the Son of God demons identify
him as the Son of God and people who
certainly didn't believe that he's the
son of God publicly proclaimed that he
was claiming to be the son of God
all three persons of the Trinity
prophets and apostles Angels and Demons
men and women Jews and Gentiles anyone
who could possibly identify Jesus as the
Son of God identified him as the son of
God
but about six centuries later
an illiterate Caravan robber who married
a six-year-old girl who married the
divorced wife of his own adopted son
after causing the divorce by lusting
after her who bought owned sold and
traded black African slaves whose first
impression of his Revelations was that
they were demonic who repeatedly tried
to kill himself this guy comes along and
tells his followers that Jesus isn't the
Son of God and never claims to be
and Muhammad's followers believed him
the least reliable person in the history
of humanity instead of believing the
unparalleled cloud of witnesses who
affirmed that Jesus is the son of God
why would Muhammad's followers believe
him when he contradicts every single
reliable witness from the first century
for the same reason they'll believe
Muhammad when he says that Jews call
Israel the Son of God even though 34
centuries of Jews will say that's
complete nonsense
Muhammad is an idol to his followers and
in the minds of his followers what
Muhammad says trumps millions of
witnesses all of history prophets Angels
even God himself
but what was Muhammad's main objection
to the claim that Jesus is the son of
God we find it in Surah 6 verse 101 of
the Quran where Allah says the inventor
of the heavens and the Earth how can he
have a son when he has no female
companion
so how can God have a son when he has no
wife
according to the Quran it's impossible
for Allah to have a son unless he has a
wife Allah declares that you can't
possibly have a son without a mommy and
a daddy it takes two to tango even Allah
Almighty himself can't make a son
without a woman
this response is hilarious for two
reasons one it completely contradicts
what Allah says in Surah 19. in Surah 19
the spirit of Allah appears to marry and
tells her that she's going to have a son
Mary replies how can I have a son when
no man has touched me
Allah answers it's easy for me so no
Daddy required did you catch that
Suddenly It's Easy for Allah to make a
son with only one parent total
contradiction
two when father son Holy Spirit Angels
prophets Apostles and so on declare that
Jesus is the son of God
are they talking about a son produced
through sexual intercourse
are they talking about God having sex
with a woman and producing Jesus as an
offspring
no so once again the god of the Quran
has no clue what he's talking about
what does Son of God mean in the Bible
well it means several things depending
on the context the one thing it never
means is that God had sex and produced
an offspring and yet according to Islam
that's the only thing it can possibly
mean
let's go through the different meanings
of Son of God in the Bible this is
important because Muslim apologists will
sometimes claim that calling Jesus the
son of God is irrelevant because other
people are called sons of God in the
Bible hence famous Sons by the tons
objection
I said look it means nothing man to say
I'm the Son of God means nothing God has
got Sons by the tons in the Bible
deducts fans were impressed by this
response because they didn't realize
what an absolute deceiver he was and
soccer Nike fans are generally some of
the most ignorant people on the planet
think about this
I could say that all human beings are
brothers we're all related
I could say that all Americans are my
brothers we're all from the same country
I could say that vocab Malone is my
brother in Christ we're both Christians
I could say that John and Manny are my
brothers we had the same mother
I would be using the word brother in
different ways in all of these claims
what I mean when I use the word brother
will depend on how I'm using the word if
I say John and Manny are my brothers
would it make sense for someone like
Ahmad to reply ah but all human beings
are brothers in a sense so David doesn't
really mean anything when he calls John
and Manny his brothers
no because they're my brothers in a
specific way you'd have to be insanely
stupid to think that a word or a phrase
like brother or son or Son of God can
only be used with one meaning
so how is the phrase Son of God used in
the Bible
let's go through some different ways
it's used
first human beings in general are called
God's children in Acts 17 because as the
Apostle Paul says in him in God we live
and move and have our being God creates
us and sustains us the idea is that as a
human father provides for his family God
provides for us though in a much more
significant way
second Spirit beings also live and move
and have their being in God so in Job 1
angels are called sons of God not only
because God creates them and sustains
them in existence but also presumably
because of their role in carrying out
God's commands
third the nation of Israel is called
God's son in Exodus 4 God tells Moses to
say to Pharaoh thus says the Lord Israel
is my firstborn son this is related to
Deuteronomy 32 where Moses says to the
nation of Israel is not he your father
who created you who made you and
established you
so the nation of Israel wasn't a normal
naturally developing Nation God produced
The Nation through divine intervention
and was therefore Israel's father
fourth the reigning davidic King The
King who was a descendant of King David
was called Son of God because he was put
on his throne by God and he was to rule
under God's Authority as God's
representative fifth people who reflect
God's will through their conduct can be
called sons of God since this gives them
a kind of family resemblance to God thus
Jesus says in The Sermon on the Mount in
Matthew 5 blessed are the peacemakers
for they shall be called sons of God
so the phrase Son of God can have a
variety of meanings in the Bible
why then do Christians think it's so
important to call Jesus the son of God
well when the father and the Holy Spirit
together identified Jesus as the beloved
Son do you think they were saying that
Jesus is the son of God like other human
beings
when the angel Gabriel and John the
Baptist identified Jesus as the Son of
God do you think they were saying that
Jesus is the son of God in some generic
sense that applies to lots of other
people
when Jesus called himself the Son of God
was he simply saying that God created
him
when Jesus was casting out demons and
the demons were screaming that he's the
son of God do you think they were only
saying blessed are the peacemakers for
they shall be called sons of God
no Jesus is the son of God in a Divine
sense it's his position in the trinity
in the first century most people thought
of a son as someone who carried on the
Family Trade Sons didn't go away to
college they did whatever their fathers
did if your father was the butcher you
were the butcher if your father was a
baker you were a baker
to say that someone is the Son of God in
this sense would mean that he does the
work that God does and this is exactly
what Jesus claims about himself consider
some examples
according to both the Bible and the
Quran God is the one who raises the dead
at the resurrection
but in John 5 Jesus says that he's the
one who will raise the dead at the
resurrection
according to both the Bible and the
Quran God is the final judge of all
mankind
but in Matthew 25 Jesus tells his
followers that he will be the final
judge of all people
according to both the Bible and the
Quran God is the one who can ultimately
forgive sins and yet Jesus claims in
Mark 2 that he's the one who ultimately
forgives sins so Jesus does the work
that only God does
and he claims to have a unique
relationship with the father in Matthew
11 Jesus says
all things have been handed over to me
by my father and no one knows the son
except the father and no one knows the
father except the son and anyone to whom
the son chooses to reveal him
and this relationship has always existed
as we read in the opening verses of the
Gospel of John in the beginning was the
word and the Word was with God and the
Word was God he was in the beginning
with God all things were made through
him and without him was not anything
made that was made
the word Jesus the son was with God and
the Word was God
how could the word be with God and be
God
it only makes sense if you're thinking
in trinitarian terms the same difficulty
arises with the phrase Son of God
Muslims ask well what was he God or the
son of God
their confusion arises because they hear
Son of God and like their Prophet they
think of God producing some sort of
separate offspring
Christians don't claim that God produced
a son as some sort of separate Offspring
we claim that within the one nature or
Essence of God the person of the son is
eternally with the person of the father
so we can talk about Jesus being the Son
of God because within the Trinity he's
the son of the father and we can talk
about him being God because he has the
same Divine Essence as the father
for some reason Muslims mock the idea of
these Eternal relationships even though
these same Muslims will tell us that the
Quran is co-eternal with Allah and that
it eternally proceeds from Allah
according to Muhammad the Quran allows
Eternal speech can even appear in the
form of a Pale Man and talk to people
so there's a person who eternally
proceeds from Allah and appears as a
Pale Man
I thought that Eternal relationships
involving God were something to be
mocked and ridiculed
so according to the Bible Jesus is the
Divine son
interestingly because he's the Divine
son he's the Supreme example of the Son
of God in all the other senses we looked
at
human beings are called sons of God but
Jesus is the greatest human being
Spirit beings are called sons of God but
Jesus is the highest spirit being
the davidic kings were called sons of
God but Jesus is the Messiah the Eternal
davidic King the nation of Israel was
called the Son of God but according to
the Bible the Messiah is the new Israel
who succeeds where Israel failed
people who reflect God's character in
their conduct are called sons of God but
Jesus is the perfect reflection of the
father's character so much so that he
could say as he does in John 14 Whoever
has seen me has seen the father
God revealed something about his eternal
nature to human beings
the appropriate response should be wow
thank you Lord
for revealing that
will try to understand what you've
revealed as far as our limited Minds
allow
unfortunately six centuries after the
Eternal Sun entered creation as Jesus of
Nazareth the most obvious false prophet
in history came along and said how can
God have a son when he has no wife
and billions of people accepted his
idiotic response
this Caravan robber has been robbing
people of the knowledge of God for 1400
years
and you want to blow up the Sphinx for
him
and take as many people with you as
possible
I can't let you do that my Muslim friend
which is why as I was distracting you
with this conversation I used my Gerber
multi-tool to cut the wires on your
suicide vest and as much as I despise
snitching I did use my phone and the SIM
card I bought to contact the authorities
I hope you'll use your time in prison to
think about what we've discussed
so that's how you save countless lives
and a precious ancient Monument from a
terrorist who asks you why Christians
call Jesus the son of God
of course I should point out that you
can share all of this information in
less dangerous situations like friendly
discussions with Muslims at your school
at work in your neighborhood
or at the Apologetics Roadshow
[Music]
thank you